air is a remarkable substance
not only does it allow us to breathe
which i think we can all agree is a good
thing
but if you compress it and contain it
you can have loads of fun
like defying the laws of physics
or for wacky furniture whack see
the secret to understanding and using
compressed air
is to realize that all it wants to do is
stop
being compressed air it wants to escape
and in so doing
air teaches us valuable science on
pressure differentials
and conservation of energy
if air in one part of a container is
compressed it will apply pressure to all
other parts
until all areas are the same pressure
this is due to conservation of energy
when a container of compressed air is
open to the atmosphere the high pressure
inside
equalizes with the lower pressure
outside producing a force
as the air escapes
and whatever is containing the
compressed air needs to have the
material strength to withstand the
pressure differential
otherwise it will fail
to sum up pressure changes will be
transferred to all parts of the
container
give something at high pressure and
opening and it will take it and escape
with force
and finally whatever you do make sure
the container you're using
is strong enough so now you know but do
our researchers know
[Music]
yes they do the jumper has cleverly
demonstrated a basic pneumatic system
he adds kinetic energy with his jump
which causes a pressure change in the
bag
and due to conservation of energy the
kinetic energy is transferred to her
and she then transfers that same energy
to the bedside table
[Music]
via her head
how about something a little more
high-tech surely these amateur rocket
engineers understand pneumatics
ah turns out they don't the young
researcher was trying to compress air
by jumping on the pump unfortunately he
misses
[Music]
but oliver doesn't when the pump is
pressed
the pressure differential created
applies a force
that launches the rocket to get a closer
look at the physics
understanding the science allows you to
take advantage of the science
like building a beach trampoline
[Music]
fun times yeah
less fun times the membrane of the beach
ball didn't have the material strength
to contain the higher pressure produced
by our more sure-footed researcher
[Music]
so
you